sie alle treten in die pedale doch
andrea sliwka ist immer einen tick
schneller
also es ist so wie im porsche gegen
fenster fahren
man hat frische luft das einfach cool es
geht einfach nur ab von null auf 25
stundenkilometer in nur ein paar
sekunden
dafür muss sich andreas oft sprüche
anhören
da ist doch immer kulturell oder ist
einer drin
der akku ist in der lenkertasche
verstaut er treibt den motor in der
hinterradnabe an
denn andreas fährt ein elektrorad ein
e-bike sein autor hat er vor einem jahr
abgeschafft also vom auto aufs fahrrad
umgestiegen aus ökologischen und
finanziellen gründen einfach viel
preiswerter und das e-bike habe ich
genommen weil ich dann doch recht viel
unterwegs bin zu meinen kunden und man
kann mit einem jeweils sagen wir mal so
bequem fahren dass man nicht verschwitzt
ankommt und das einzige müffelt im
meeting 3000 euro hat der
veranstaltungstechniker für sein
elektrorad hingelegt das besondere er
kann es in einer minute zusammenfalten
so kann er es auch mit denen die bahn
nehmen
denn egal wo seine kunden wohnen mit rat
und zug kommt er überall hin unter not
passt es auch in ein auto ich werde bei
den kunden oft darauf angesprochen warum
ich dann so schnell da bin oder kein
parkplatz gesucht habe parkplätze muss
engagement ebenfalls keine mehr suchen
auch sie hat ihren familien wagen
eingetauscht gegen ein familien e-bike
den zwei kinder und es ist einfach
wesentlich praktischer wenn man überlegt
dass der 40 kilo hinten dran sind die
wegzuziehen als wenn man das ganz
normalen fahrrad zieht und man hat
einfach die möglichkeit auf weitere
strecken zurückzulegen
wo man sonst vielleicht auf ein auto
zurückgreifen würde distanzen von 30
kilometer sind für sie mit der
elektrounterstützung kein problem mehr
der einzige haken der akku der macht
nach rund 50 kilometern schlapp ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass ich das in
den nächsten jahren technisch verbessert
aber wenn man jetzt mal eine weitere
fahrradtour machen will muss man einigen
zweitakku mitschleppen
wenn man das sonst nicht schafft davon
ließen sich aber 300.000 deutsche nicht
abschrecken
sie haben im vergangenen jahr ein e bike
gekauft 1000 euro kostet das einfachste
5000 die mountainbike variante treten
muss man bei fast allen aber immer noch
denn der motor springt erst an wenn
druck auf die pedale kommt es gibt
verschiedene systeme bei den meisten ist
es so gesehen ist es bewegung da oder
dass es druck auf dem pedal und dann
wird gerechnet so und so viel druck
machte und so viel kraft das wird dann
auf die kette oder indirekt das
hinterrad gegeben
500 watt geben die starken motoren dazu
damit fährt man fast so schnell wie ein
motorroller wie viel kraft der motor
dazu schießen soll
kann man über den tacho einstellen die
meisten ebay käufer wohnen übrigens
nicht in der stadt sondern in dem
bergigen regionen fahren laufen land
freuen sich richtig weil viel läuft der
stadt dauert noch ein bisschen
wir brauchen infrastruktur um mit den
fahrern gut fahren zu können das ist das
was in der stadt fehlt nämlich radwege
bzw
freie straßen und vor allem auch
parkmöglichkeiten dass das rad nachts
sicher abstellen kann deutschland ist
der größte e bike markt europas gefolgt
von holland und der schweiz
das rad mit dem elektromotor boomt und
hat das potenzial zum statussymbol zu
werden
irgendwann werden leute sagen ich habe
aber nie bike mit allradantrieb und mit
saphir bremsen gott weiß was bestimmt
wird es um ein statussymbol